you foresaw the Trump's potential
victory you picked a bunch of these
states in the Rust Belt yeah you saw
something happening how did you see this
happening when so many people missed it
well first of all there's these these
people I just call them now data dummies
who all they can look at in politics and
talk about is the data and the polls and
the numbers and this sort of stuff my
life is a focus group okay I go to
different colleges I sing for my supper
I'm on TV I'm on Twitter and I started
noticing stuff for instance if you got
on stage even now and you say Barack
Obama people go nuts if you get on stage
for instance Barack Obama if you get on
stage and you say Donald Trump people go
nuts usually the other way Donald Trump
you get some yeah some applause get some
applause get some reaction but I would
say Hillary Clinton's name and it would
be crickets hmm and I said something's
wrong something's are something it's not
being data the data was all saying 95
percent chance she's gonna be President
93 percent chance she's gonna be
President well first of all I'm sorry
excuse me if there is a five percent
chance it's still a chance shouldn't you
take it seriously yeah we were like oh
it's only a five percent tonight I'm
like it's a five percent chance of an
asteroid destroying the earth you might
want to get busy you might want to do
something right no it was all I'm not
gonna worry about and I saw people
working harder to stop Mitt Romney and
John McCain then I saw them working to
stop Trump now people they tweeted they
repost it they posted but as far as
going the swing states and working the
people complaining now did not do that
that the house parties the phone banking
it was all almost empty and so I was
saying why wouldn't you work so hard to
stop at John McCain and then do nothing
to stop Trump except to say Oh Trump is
terrible that's not going to stop him in
a bit
you